hey guys it is Thursday December the
17th my name is Jess and here's what
mattered in gaming today according to a
polygon report the retail edition of
PlayStation VR will arrive with a pretty
sizable purchasing unit PlayStation VI
units require the external blocks to
provide additional processing power for
graphics rendering VR headsets usually
need a lot of power behind them as they
essentially need to output two different
images one for each eye the headset will
plug into the unit which is then
connected to the ps4 all that sounds
pretty acceptable but according to
polygon the device is almost the size of
the Nintendo Wii unfortunately pictures
of the device were not permitted at the
recent preview event the way is about a
third the size of the ps4 or three DVD
cases stacked on top of each other so
that should give you a good idea of what
you'll be our headset will need to plug
into the Gran Turismo franchise has now
sold almost 70 6.5 million units
according to develop a telephony digital
telephony digital updated their website
with the new figures which indicate that
the racing simulator franchise has sold
76.4 9 million copies as of September 30
across the series of ten major
installment the best-selling game in the
series is 2001 is Gran Turismo 3 a spec
for ps2 which sold 14.8 9 million copies
comparatively the worst spelling is Gran
Turismo 4 prologue which shifted just
1.4 million copies after its launch in
2003 to be fair this was a much smaller
game and was not released in north
america the comparisons sake the Halo
series has sold 65 million copies while
franchises including mario pokemon Final
Fantasy fifa and GTA all exceed 100
million units each the next game in the
series if granturismo sport which will
arrive in 2016 with gran turismo 7
reportedly arriving in twenty sixteen to
twenty seventeen microsoft have revealed
the next collection of xbox 360 games
that will be playable on xbox one
through backward
compatibility 16 new games will be
accessible through the feature may
include braids deus ex human revolution
fable three Taylor reach solanki and
portal still alive there are now 120
xbox 360 games with backwards
compatibility support on xbox one and
Microsoft are promising to add new games
to the service on a regular basis the
publisher also announced that since its
launch people have logged more than 9
million hours playing xbox 360 games on
xbox one among the most popular are
fallout 3 gears of war just cause two
and assassin's creed two currently the
most requested xbox 360 games for
backward compatibility our pool of duty
black ops 2 Skyrim and red dead
redemption let me know down in that
comment section which xbox 360 game
you'd like to see come to xbox one next
and we should i head to games but where
we've got stories on street fighter 5
and Dragon's Dogma for PC that is
everything I have you today but do come
by same time tomorrow my top 5 stories
of the whole week and our last episode
of the year I will catch you in